STATE OF VIMEO:
Remember Vimeo? Back
in the late 2000s and early 2010s, if you searched
for a video on Google, you would see a few results
from Vimeo and DailyMotion. Personally, I always
thought of Vimeo as just a YouTube copycat that
wasn’t nearly as popular but it turns out that
Vimeo was and still is way more popular than
you might imagine. In fact, Vimeo has a total of
230 million users from over 190 countries out of
which 90 million are active every month. Vimeo
also boasts 60 million content creators and a
video catalog that is growing by as much as 900
million videos per year. But, this sizable user
base is pretty much the only thing that Vimeo
has going for them as everything else has turned
against them. Basically just one look at their
stock will tell you everything you need to know.
Since going public in 2021, it’s been straight
down for Vimeo who has lost 93% of their market
value which has dipped down to $625 million. At
this point, they’re almost trading at book value
which isn’t all that much lower. Vimeo has a total
of $610 million worth of assets and $243 million
worth of liabilities, so their net assets stand
at $367 million. If we subtract this from Vimeo’s
current market valuation, we’ll see that the
business portion of Vimeo is only worth about $250
million. For perspective, YouTube pulls in
that much revenue every 3 days. Seeing this,
I don’t think you’d be surprised to see that
Vimeo has a bankruptcy probability of 25% over
the next 24 months. Given this bleak situation,
Vimeo has been cutting resources and staff but
this has only made the platform worse which has
turned the community against the company, the
last thing they had going for them. So Vimeo is in
this super precarious situation where they still
have nearly a quarter billion users but all they
have to show for it is a company that’s slowly
bleeding towards bankruptcy and an increasingly
frustrated user base. And you know what the kicker
about all of this is? Vimeo was never the YouTube
copycat, they were actually the OG YouTube having
launched a couple of months before YouTube.
So, here’s the tragic fate of the OG YouTube.
ACCIDENTAL CREATION:
Taking a look back,
the story of Vimeo traces back to late 2004 to two
web developers named Jake Lodwick and Zach Klein.
Neither of these guys were some sort of tech
wizards that dropped out of Harvard or something.
They were just modest software engineers working
at a company that they thought was fun and light
hearted: CollegeHumor. This was back when people
actually used to watch TV and this one SNL clip
about the singer Ashlee Simpson was garnering a
lot of attention. Basically, Ashlee missed her
entry on live television which made it painfully
obvious that she was lip syncing. She tried to
play it off by as no big deal by dancing but this
was unfortunately the end of her singing career.
The sliver lining of the situation is that this
event is what also gave rise to Vimeo. You see,
the day after this incident, the video clip would
go viral online on all sorts of platforms one of
which was CollegeHumor. Jake and Zach saw this
explosion first hand and decided that it would
be neat to create a platform dedicated to tagging
and sharing short videos just like this. So, they
whipped together a site and came up the name Vimeo
which was a combination of the words video and me.
The website would go live soon after in November
of 2004 but that was pretty much it. From there,
the website would just organically grow through
word of mouth while Jake and Zach focused on
helping scale CollegeHumor. It wasn’t till nearly
2 years later till the duo would really look back
at the site. You see, in August of 2006, Barry
Diller, the founder of Fox and USA Broadcasting
would make an acquisition offer for the parent
company of College Humor: Connected Ventures.
And during the due diligence phase, his team
would come across Vimeo. They didn’t think
much of it and offered to buy out everything for
a total of $26 million. Just a couple of weeks
later though a news bomb would drop from Google.
They were gonna acquire YouTube for $1.65 billion.
Diller immediately realized that he had just
accidentally struck gold and would tell everyone
at Connected Ventures to go all in on Vimeo with
Jake and Zach leading the effort. By this point,
YouTube had already become the sort of mass
market video sharing platform, so instead of
going after popularity, Jake and Zach decided to
go after quality. As such, they would focus their
efforts on better curating content and offering a
better creator and user experience. One of these
efforts was bring HD streaming to online video.
In fact, in October of 2007, Vimeo would become
the first online video sharing platform to
support HD streaming out of the box. But,
not all was great at Vimeo. As Diller became more
and more concerned about making Vimeo successful,
he would assert more and more influence over
the company. For example, he would implement
a traditional corporate structure like he had
at his media companies and bring in a bunch of
his trusted associates. But this simply created
a larger and larger rift between the original
Vimeo team and the new members. Eventually, this
tension would blow over and Jake would decide to
leave but before he could, he would actually get
fired in late 2007. Just a couple of months later,
Zach would also leave the company, and ever since
then, it’s only been downhill for the company.
PIVOT AFTER PIVOT:
With the founders out, Vimeo
would decide to go all in on a complete redesign
of the platform. They wanted the video player to
be the central focus of any page unlike YouTube.
They would also implement a lot of restrictions
around what could and could not be uploaded to
Vimeo. Essentially, they only wanted high ROI
content which was shorter videos that could appeal
to a broad audience. And this tunnel visioned goal
led to some pretty odd choices. For example,
starting in 2008, they would ban all gaming
content. The reasoning was that gaming content
tended to be long and take up a lot of resources
while only appealing to a niche group of returning
viewers. They did eventually lift this ban in 2014
but this gave YouTube a full 6 years to blow
up in all sorts of niches that Vimeo creators
couldn’t even post about. By this point, there was
no catching up to YouTube, so Vimeo would double
down on trying to appeal to indie filmmakers and
creatives. For example, in 2010, they would launch
the Vimeo Festival and Awards Program. This was
basically a competition for rising filmmakers
to show off their work and gain exposure. Around
the same tim, they would introduce 4K downloading
support and in 2015, they would launch 4K
streaming support. Vimeo also boasted far
less compression than YouTube in order to better
protect the creator’s original vision. But while
these efforts were able to build a strong
base of creatives, Vimeo was aiming for much
more than that. So, it late 2016, they announced
their plans to spend tens of millions of dollars
on creating original in house content to compete
against Netflix. If this sounds like a crazy out
there idea, it was and thankfully, they didn’t go
too far off the deep end before calling it quits
just one year later. Vimeo was back to ground
zero. They needed a new way to pivot and continue
growing but with competing against YouTube
and Netflix directly being off the table,
they really had no direction until they talked
to a rising leader named Anjali Sud. Sud was a
U Penn and Harvard graduate that was currently
servering as the head of global marketing for
Vimeo. And Sud had a completely different vision
for Vimeo. Instead of being a consumer business,
what if they became an enterprise busines. There
were a lot of businesses that were left behind by
the age of the internet. So, what if they helped
these businesses create promotional videos and get
feedback before sharing it online? With not much
to lose, Vimeo’s board would approve the pivot and
place Sud as the new CEO of Vimeo in July of 2017.
Sud would go onto rebrand Vimeo as a SAAS platform
and release a slew of editing and review tools.
She would also complete multiple acquisitions that
brought in tens of millions of new users to Vimeo.
For example, in early 2019, she purchased Magisto,
an AI video creation service with over a
hundred million users. And in late 2021,
Vimeo would purchase yet another AI based video
creation platform called Wibbitz. While this was
a rather unexpected direction for Vimeo, it seemed
like things were paying off. Enterprise customers
quickly become Vimeo’s fastest growing segment
accounting for the majority of company’s revenue.
Their user count was also exploding thanks to the
pandemic reaching over 200 million by late 2020.
But the reality was the Vimeo was a lot more
fragile than any of these numbers suggested.
THE GREAT COLLAPSE:
One key point that we have yet to discuss
is how exactly Vimeo makes money which turns out
to be the company’s biggest shortfall. Naturally,
you would think that Vimeo makes money off of
ads just like any other video sharing or social
media platform. But, Vimeo actually shows no ads
at all. Given that Vimeo targetted a higher end
user base of film makers and creatives, they
didn’t want to bog down the platform with a
bunch of ads. And as such, the only way that
Vimeo makes money is from creators and viewers
directly paying them. Creators and businesses
have to pay a fee based on how many videos they
upload and what features they want. And Vimeo
also gets a 10% commission on any money that
users are willing to support creators with.
It’s a pretty straight forward model but it’s
not all that profitable. In fact, despite having
over 200 million users, Vimeo was only pulling
in a little more than $400 million per year or
barely $2 per user per year. For perspective,
YouTube pulls in closer to $11 per user per year
and Facebook pulls in over $20 per user per year.
And given that video storage isn’t exactly
cheap especially uncompressed video storage,
Vimeo has never really been profitable.
Throughout much of Sud’s leadership,
she just raised a bunch of money to make up
for this disparity. For example, in 2020,
she raised $150 million and 2021 she raised $300
million. But all of this peaked in mid 2021 when
she decided to take the company public at a $10
billion valuation. The harsh reality was that
investors simply didn’t care about investing in a
second tier video streaming platform, especially
one that was losing money when they could just
invest in Google or Netflix. On IPO day itself,
Vimeo would fall 13% and it’s only been downhill
since then. As such, Vimeo has very much started
focusing on turning a profit which has led to
some pretty unpopular decisions. On one side,
they’ve been cutting resources which has led
to widespread buffering issues. It also seems
that Vimeo’s UI is starting to feel dated and
their video curation has very much fallen behind
industry standards something that they used
to lead. But likely their most controversial
decision by far was jacking up prices for content
creators, especially their most popular and active
creators. In some cases, creators were expected
to pay thousands of dollars just to keep their
content on Vimeo. While extremely unpopular
though, these drastic measures have allowed
to company to barely become profitable. They’re
currently pulling in about $8 million per year,
but at what cost? They’re basically stuck in
no mans land with a bunch of angry users and
no real way to move forward. Sud has since been
forced to step down and has been replaced by a
long time cloud executive named Adam Gross. Given
that Vimeo has been able to achieve profitability,
I don’t seem them going under anytime per se
but it’s also hard to see a bright future ahead
for Vimeo either which is quite a shame given that
they were the OG video streaming platform. YouTube
seems to be facing their own crisis with ads and
short form hell. Check out this video learn more.